es hört hier kommt am 20
heute allerdings nicht immer wunderschön
ist t shirt denen meine lieben freunde
denn ihr seht es bereits daran des amtes
und anhand des drittels meine lieben
freunde wir gehen heute mal wieder
gemeinsam erfolge du hast du hätte
[Musik]
die nieten es einfach nicht mehr aus und
wollen beweisen da noch die emotionale
reise an den tag legen können
mein cooler onkel in der letzten folge
ging es ja um den emotionalen reife
workshop- und der ist jetzt anscheinend
beendet allerdings wollen die mädels
zeigen dass sie auch emotionale reife
besitzen also ich bin gespannt die
gucken jetzt einfach den jungs seien
dabei
super wie er das macht mit einer
emotionalen reife mädels
[Musik]
unsere lampe ich hätte nie gedacht dass
es mich so mitnehmen würde dass wir uns
unsere schwächen eingestehen ich glaube
es war wirklich ein guter mensch ums
leben
freunde fürs leben denn jetzt haben
gefühlt alle stress da untereinander in
real life wieder lukas können shop.com
ich verstehe nicht warum von chats kann
nicht einfach mal zu harry hingeht und
ihm sagt ja sorry dass ich mit pelz
darum gefördert habe ich stehe ein
kräftig dann wäre alles viel offener und
interessanter kommen die männer raus
das ist einer der schönsten orte die ich
kenne ja das stimmt das nicht
wunderschön da ich will den urlaub die
sind allerdings von der insel werden
ich mag dein haar naja das ist ein
kompliment von hey ich glaub ich muss
mich kurz setzen
das ist echt zu dasding ne haley hast
einfach alles und jeden
ich habe nachdem ich jetzt den letzten
tagen ja auch von jazz und harry's
braker video reagiert habe immer so ein
paar videos in meinen kommentar
vorschlägen von teilnehmern die auch bei
turner dabei war und dabei auch ein
video von haley von wegen warum sie denn
alles im leben gehabt hat ich mir auch
gedacht und die hat ein video sogar dazu
hochgeladen das ist nicht nur meine
ansicht dass sie anscheinend gegen alle
da irgendwie was hat sondern es war
wirklich so ich verstehe nicht wie man
so negativ belastet durchs leben laufen
kann
jerome hat viele probleme und ich bin
sehr dankbar dass er mich trotzdem an
sich an lässt er ist auf dem weg ein
besserer mann zu werden und das ist
großartig wirklich gut ich freue mich
auch für die 2 sag mal kennt ihr das
wenn so ein muskel von euch die ganze
zeit am zocken lässt ich weiß ja
eigentlich keine muskeln aber der hier
ich hätte fast geweint und dachte bis
zum cio nahles die beiden sind echt gute
kameraposition
mega mega ich habe das gefühl ich habe
mich weiterentwickelt ja sehr gut ist
echt krass
gedacht dass die serie zigmal so
entwickelt zusammen tiefgründigen ding
also ich nicht jetzt geht s los oder wie
mission harry kannst dass du kriegst ich
weiß was
ich glaube wir jeweils jetzt sogar ihre
fingernägel passend zum top lackiert ich
würde nicht nein sagen von chaska nach
köln kommen wie ein idiot russland ja ja
keiner verkabeln sie und harry natürlich
was geht plötzlich sitzen sie da umgeben
von kameras also es ist schon sehr sehr
fake die sendung trotzdem finde ich dass
ich sehr cool rüber bringen und so
weiter und so fort ich bin einfach
gespannt
es ist dumm dass ich sage ich bin
gespannt ob die zusammenkommen
wir wissen ja schon dass sie zusammen
kommen einfach reden ein paar dinge über
die ich mit ihm sprechen wollte
blick wieder ein echter vor gedrückt
weil ich nicht weiß wie du reagieren
würde
das ist neu für mich denn ich bin keine
frau die männer nachjagen muss oder so
also ihr seid alle so selbstbewusst in
dieser sendung
unfassbar auch ein skate sagen kann
meinte ja normalerweise krieges müde
aber das ist mir egal wenn von jobs
kommt auch neuere oder auch chloe damals
normalerweise bin ich jetzt direkt mit
dem typen hochgehen und nehmen sie
dieses selbstbewusstsein her ich hatte
seit 7000 jahren kann ich hab das
einfach nicht geschafft nicht aus dem
kopf zu kriegen
das ist hart ich bin gespannt was harry
sagte wenn du ablehnen es gar keinen dem
verhalten wohl alle gucken sommer ich
bin da ist noch was ich gespannt was
dabei rumkommt
ich bin ultra stuhl weise finde ich
jetzt abhauen ich blocke nie wieder sagt
und wie denkt ihr schon so nah
normalerweise würde ich jetzt ab und
blockieren das ist genau das was herr
jetzt in seinem in dem real life jetzt
gemacht hat nachdem die beiden sich
jetzt getrennt aber heute ist er auch
einfach abgehauen sagt schütz kann das
nicht mehr czarkowski kaká aus san
francisco und rugby
hat er auch noch geschrieben oh ja
luca ist schön wenn es wieder wie es
vorher war
ich will meine zeit mit keinem außerdem
verbringen
ja ok schwierig
nicht einmal sagen was er gesagt hat es
ja ich bin stur normalerweise ist
blockiert
und dann kann wieder zehn minuten
monolog von francesca sag doch mal mit
kers hat mich echt mitgenommen ich war
angedacht ist seit ihr egal
aneinander vorbeigeredet wieder eine
parade beispiel schlechthin für
missachtete kommunikationswege oder
student und ich hab da eine masche rein
verletzt aber wenig schwächer ja das
stimmt das stimmt natürlich fast eine
masche doch sogar ganz genau gesagt ja
harry blabla jetzt mache ich mir was mit
carols und vielleicht sieht dass harry
und sieht damals er mir verloren kann er
natürlich war es der mannschaft und
ceska masche so ein komisches wort
allgemein wenn man so ein paar wörter
nach banane ist auch so ein richtig
komisches wort oder also wenn man und
was hat harry als dazu
er guckt nur
er sagt nichts da kannst du nicht
einfach sagen ja du hast darüber
philosophiert von den zwischen leuchtend
reich anzufangen im vor drei folgen der
schläge oder kurs ich glaube ich weiß es
nicht
mich regt es auf den doch
ihr plötzlich an ich weiß dass das
schwer horch war also was noch immer
machen musste mir fällt es schwer zu
vergehen ja ja ich weiß nicht was du
weisst nicht unserem wissen dazu will
das kann doch nicht sein dass jetzt in
zehn minuten bereits zum schnacken kommt
da denn jetzt noch irgend etwas
konstruktives
oder
das passiert so etwas
das war jetzt nicht
das sport okay jetzt kommt jetzt harry
der zum sterben schön frau seiner träume
francesca verzeihen erhofft klappt ich
weiß es nicht vielleicht ja vielleicht
nein aber die war nach der show und
gefühlten halbes jahr zu sagen also ich
glaube ja doch diesem tag hätte ich dich
stehen lassen
okay ich habe dort gelernt alles in der
vergangenheit zulassen werden ja das
mache ich doch an
das macht ihr beiden jetzt auch gerade
ihr lasst eure beziehung in der
vergangenheit francesca bei mir ohne uns
eine chance zu geben wäre das eine echte
verschwender krass der auch schon harte
tour herr kommissar ad wir haben beide
noch einen langen weg vor uns und wenn
wir es wirklich noch mal versuchen ja
wissen wir uns ein paar dinge
versprechen okay ja was ich sage ja was
und kik aufbau sich vollidiot erstens
mit anderen herr ist schluss musste mir
und unsere beziehung 110 prozent liebt
salami irgendwie mit kälte und hitze
hingegen mit jesus und mit sharon
wonderwall pulver karriere auf jeden
fall verstehen rede mit mir los war
etwas sage ich will nicht dass die
person im jahr meisten bedeutet sauer
auf mich ist reden ist das aller aller
aller aller wichtigste nicht und einer
liebesbeziehung sondern auch in einer
freundschaftlichen beziehungen wenn es
probleme gibt einfach aussprechen es
macht keinen sinn dass in syke zu
pressen psychologe mal wieder am start
drittens keine regelbrüche
entweder harry versucht von chester mit
einem hattrick ins bett zu kriegen ohne
er hat tatsächlich fortschritte gemacht
ich glaube ja ich fühle mich wie ein
mann der nach vorn stimmt wirklich
er stimmt wirklich
es ist so heftig wie diese serie alle
irgendwie gefüllt umgekrempelt hat klar
man weiß nie wie viel davon als fake wie
viel wird vorher gesagt hey sagt marlies
sagt man dass man weiß nicht wie dieses
ganze kontaktverbot wirklich
durchgezogen wurde ein kontaktverbot
ich lebe schon wieder hier in zeiten von
cola es ist wie nach hause kam
das ist doch ein schönes schlusswort
freunde dann der zelle durch die heutige
reaktion auf die aktuelle jetzt auch
beendet wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
das gerne einen darunter video das
schaffen wir 60.000 like das ist ein
mega krass und wird mit zeigen hey ihr
habt weiterhin bock auf reactions von
mir zu dieser serie und werde weiter in
bottrop hat dann abonniert doch gerne
meinen kanal hier oben auf den smiley
einfach draufklicken das ist kostenlos
und verpasst keine video sperren wenn
ihr meine letzte rage of you are ten
verpasst haben sollte dann kriegt man
hier
da ist sie nämlich verlinkt und dieses t
shirt hier auch megane alten bereits
gesagt zwanzigster siebter 2020 und 1500
ps ist unfassbar leisten fast normal
allerdings